Bobby a bear is the former Saints
quarterback he works pregame halftime
postgame for the Saints WWL radio and
Bobby joins us now how's the voice today
Bobby well dad I'll tell you what
you know supposed to scream in the press
box but my head is still ringing and it
wouldn't be hurting as much if the
Saints would have won the game and I got
a Saturday for you okay it was just the
Saints first lost this season when
holding the opponent's scoreless on the
opening drive hmm so the Saints were
eight I know before Sunday so I thought
when that happened the Saints are gonna
win getting off to a great start in the
first quarter it was probably the
loudest first quarter in NFL history you
know that was the loudest Stadium in a
game I think it was the loudest first
quarter the the Rams look so
dysfunctional they could not communicate
I think they did they're just as well
considering how the game turned out why
did this why was this game so close if
this is a Saints team at home Drew Brees
and Sean Payton don't lose home games in
the playoffs and you're up 13 to nothing
well I can tell you Brees the latter
part of season did not play great you
know he was up to MVP he can't just be
good he has to be great and they didn't
get touchdowns in the red zone if you
look there were only two or five and you
say well no they have not struggled in
the red zone they had the fourth best
red zone offense threat did you look at
the Eagles they were the number one red
zone defense and the two games when they
played the Eagles they end up with seven
to eight and the red zone getting
touchdown so that was they didn't finish
when you're getting the red zone you
can't set over field goals when that
game started and it was six to zero you
know Dan Arnold drops the touchdown pass
the division three player he does it
that the moments too big for him instead
of six zero it should have been 10 0 or
14-0 at that point and we know how close
the game was so that all those little
things make a difference what did you
see in real time on the controversial
call no call real time not even a
judgment call it was obvious you know
judgment called to me is bang bang or
whatever no it was so obvious you could
be a hundred yards away and and throw
the flag that's why I think listen I
think officials Eagles they don't want
to step on each other so they kind of
okay I'm afraid to call that because you
know maybe that's not the area that I
need to be throwing the flag but you got
to get it right the bottom line you got
to get it right there was more than one
penalty on that play I mean to me when
you break it down this is the worst no
call in NFL history the reason why is
the worst no call on NFL history because
that was an on call to go to the Super
Bowl
it wasn't week four or five ha we lost a
tough one now we got to bounce back and
this even though this was to go to the
Super Bowl now it was like 98 percent
chance they're gonna win if you just
make that call now you can always miss
the field go - if shot it's even closer
than an extra point and the rest in
theory would have had about a 2% chance
to win you know maybe I don't know this
Rams miracle like it was in Minneapolis
but they'd had like 15 seconds the
bottom line is the Saints got job but
then I know exactly what the NFL needs
to do and just the optics of this it to
look right you could not have an
official from Los Angeles or from
California doing the Rams our charges
game for instance you could not have an
official because this goes on right now
you cannot have official from Louisiana
or from the Gulf Coast the Gulf South
because we got fans all the way Mobile
Alabama Pensacola Florida to the Saints
game it just it does not look good when
you have me because everyone grew up
somewhere to me like fringes vetos
california referees you got to go do the
Patriots Chiefs game you don't you know
do the local team and I think the NFL
has to address this you know that the
cost of flying these officials all over
having them really a full-time because
somebody has they have to be held
competent because that is a call that
you cannot miss you cannot even miss
that call in high school or any time
that would be interference whether is a
40s 50
sixteen any decade of football that
that's an obvious interference going at
the NFL level to go to the Super Bowl
come on that it costs people a lot of
money a lot of players a lot of Lies a
lot of legacies that's why it's
unacceptable okay but you're saying that
it's just the optics of having a referee
from California or is there a bias that
you think was there consciously or
subconsciously well you don't need that
perception because the betting public or
how the public views think the same
thing in college football when you look
at the SEC and you look how with
football crazy down here and what
officials call what games I think it
makes a difference that you cannot
afford that there has to be everything
has to look the perception on the
up-and-up because the people they'll
just say oh well well that person is
from Los Angeles and you might MIT might
say well oh I'm an honest individual but
I think it's human nature you never know
with lizard-like they've never had
scandals before they look European
Italians professional soccer I mean look
what happened in the NBA I mean that's
why to me you have to avoid that
possibly down the road I mean how can
the individual not call our some body on
and that crew throw the flag it wasn't
like bangbang it was so obvious you
could you could be over a hundred yards
away make that call talking to Bobby a
bear former Saints quarterback he's now
a broadcaster for the Saints on WWL
radio trying to get over what happened
the miracle in Minneapolis last year I
commend the Saints for being able to
recover I really have doubts about how
they'll recover if they recover from
something like this Bobby as talented as
they are this one's hard to get over
what happened in Minneapolis that's
devastating this one I think this is
going to stay with you a long time what
do you think about the Saints trying to
get over this next season well I could
say this right now and this is coming
out of Sean pains mouth in the prep of
postgame press conference he said that
probably never get over yeah no I am
telling you might say well time heals
everything but uh when something like
this happened cuz you're so close but so
far to go to the Super Bowl that Vikings
game was a division game this just go to
Super Bowl listen this ain't going
anywhere the states have a young enough
team and what I mean by that they're
gonna have double-digit wins the Saints
are still in the hunt but what does that
mean you have a good you have a great
competitive team it's hard to get to the
Super Bowl that's why it's amazing to me
with Belichick and Tom Brady what
they've done in the 21st century and
free agents in it is astounding I mean
people don't realize how hard that is to
do and the Saints right now they didn't
really take advantage of Drew Brees
winning one Super Bowl in 2011 they
broke that you greatest show on turf
they broke all the rams records in 2011
they took that five turnovers took the
league twice with five minutes left in
the game against the 49ers in the world
they loves that game we all know what
happened last year the slaves with with
a lot of luck right now could have could
have been in three Super Bowls for sure
- I mean it is it is that hard to get
there and like I said the Saints are
right there but what does that mean it
doesn't guarantee you anything because
the team's changes new faces you got to
start all over again
no and now right now this heart it's a
tough pill to swallow it is just as the
fans are just devastated here because
they had so much hoping this team and
realistically but you look from the
beginning to the end the Saints were in
the conversation they're not they
weren't the best team they were in that
conversation did you want to fight
somebody after that game ended fights oh
my I can't say this is terrible it's
like if the rocket eight is the
officials could not stay in New Orleans
that to move hotels they had moved a
hotel to no one you were there at out of
town at least 15 miles they had to get
out of Dodge they had to leave New
Orleans and I don't know I don't want to
threaten anyone but it was it was this
is the NFL's lucky that wasn't a riot in
the door
those kind of things could cause a riot
at home now the reason why there was no
riot and everyone was so frustrated
because there's no Rams fans then like
12 RAM fans in the whole dome now they
would have played a team like the Eagles
who has a strong fan base and the
cowgirls like Dallas know some could
have went down that is not good for the
NFL you never want to see that we never
want to be Europe where you have
security and you know there are soccer
games and football hooligans however you
know describe them but no is that
serious you could not listen a judgment
calls a judgment call but that was
beyond any type of judgment Bobby give
your boy some rest all right oh I'm like
I'm still stressed out Thank You Bobby
good to talk to you again all right all
right dad
that's the Cajun cannon Bobby a bear
also played in the USFL played for the
Saints I love that accent
I love that accent if you missed any of
our interviews this week from the
mercedes-amg man cave just go to the Dan
Patrick show app where you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg man
cave mercedes-amg driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]